so how did you break up the UI into
smaller components well you might have
thought that this could be two columns
but then it would be hard to position
two elements here you could Center them
vertically within the height of the
screen but it wouldn't necessarily line
up with the temperature views on the
left-hand side instead this looks more
like a horizontal linear layout then the
rest of the elements could be laid out
by using a vertical linearlayout
the vertical linearlayout would have six
children the third element would be a
horizontal linear layout composed of two
children the first would be another
vertical linear layout with these two
taxis and the second element would be
another vertical linear layout composed
of these two elements to make the
contents of the whole screen vertically
scrollable we put it inside a scrollview
using a ListView here with the overkill
because we don't need to scale to an
infinite number of item and we don't
need recycling there's a fixed number of
fields on the screen so scrollview is a
perfect choice I can show you our
implementation for the fragment detail
XML layout we hard-coded some data in
the layout so that it would show up as a
preview in the design pane at the root
of the view hierarchy we have a scroll
view scroll views can only have max one
child so we set that to be the vertical
linear layout inside of this layout we
have a textview for the day of the week
the calendar date and then a horizontal
linear layout this is followed by the
humidity textview wind textview and
pressure textview in the XML code we see
the scroll view with the child linear
layout we give it some padding of 16
dips so that the content is not flush up
against the edge of the screen then we
see the text views followed by the
horizontal linear layout we specify
layout margin top of 16 tip to give it
some more space from the bottom of this
text view within this horizontal linear
layout we have one vertical linear
layout which has a width of 0 and a
weight of 1 and another linear layout
with a width of 0 and a weight of 1 that
means that both of these children have
equal width for this linear layout we
specify gravity to the center horizontal
that means that the contents inside of
it will be centered horizontally which
includes the icon as well as the
forecast textview lastly we have the
remaining text views for the other
weather details when the layout looks
good we update the detail fragment at
this point we also move it into its own
file in the unload finished method we
used to have a fine view by ID call to
find
textview now that the detail fragment
has a lot more views we don't want to
continue adding even more fine view by
ID calls here because it will have to
traverse the view hierarchy
every time that the loader refreshes
instead we modify the oncreateview
method once the fragment is inflated we
go ahead and find a reference to all the
views that we're going to need later on
we store these views as member variables
of the class which is why the name start
with the letter M in the oncreate loader
method we make sure that the projection
for our content provider query contains
all the information that we need it's
declared at the top of the file before
we had it called forecast columns but we
just renamed it to detail columns and we
also added some more columns because now
we're displaying more information on
this screen then in the onload finished
method we get a cursor back with the
data we need we read the weather
condition ID from the cursor because
we're going to need it to determine
which image to display but for now we
can use a placeholder icon we continue
reading from the cursor to get the date
the description and the other fields to
format the data properly for the user we
also copied over the strings and the
utility method from the gist